[Music]
xxr Ludong's
[Music] I
have ana I took
ran It
seems like I taught Paris sugar
ne yodon wa nan first e you say itme
[music]
ana
yeah yeah me [music] dogs xyd
[music]
I can't make my makeup pretty if I put it on.
Height:
155 cm Weight: 41 kg
Blond hair: gray hair
No foreign affairs fee
: 3 million starts
It does
n't sound like a
hole.  It's about as
big as you want it to be
, so if you drop it at a low price, you won't mind If you
want to see your mother, then you
have to clean it after all
[Music] From
Alvan Kingdom
14 years old Height 145 cm Weight 38 kg
People have silver eyes
How many girls have I made you cry until now
Enter the Heisei Era?
I'm doing it without a weak crew coming
wh black
yeah yeah yeah I'm here ah ah ah
[music] Run
away after that
rr wh  I'll lend you some piercings,
but I made a shop, yeah, yeah,
none
I had
than cleats  aname
[music]
Also, Mr. Rooney, who was the signal for the tart
After all, this Duke of Ride is black Thank you.
They attacked the village under the guise of
kidnapping a girl and then another nobleman
took over.
Bandit miners and human trafficking is a
felony, crossing borders and endangering the international situation
.
Ternet Confirmation
The assassin aristocrat is eliminated based on the late night of Hard.
Tan Nachi next dispatches
McDonnell in front of the sedan 20 feet on the left.
Tell me what's hidden behind the plate first.
n
4 We are the organization's tools. The day the order came.
If that annihilation was the goal, the organization ordered it
.
Perhaps this time, the
purpose is to replace the upper management while leaving
the mafia structure intact.  The possibility of infiltration
I can't kill it arbitrarily It's according to the
plan I'm
withdrawing
What are you going to do? As I said, the
border guards are coming.
I run with the headlights turned
off Vertically and horizontally, I hang it from the ceiling and drop the buyer on the trigger
If the gun shakes on a rough road, it will
launch at a moment's notice.
We were chasing the car that
was supposed to continue
If I do,
I'll definitely fight back.  Yes, when the
drone finds it, it seems that the
mafia made a mistake,
or the
border patrol has already left.
It's easy to find
4 is over and the temperature of the ground exceeds that of humans, and
then it moves.Till then, rest
.
I was taught the art of
assassination and grew up only to
assassinate, so assassination is my only way of life.
For me, who lived in the midst of life,
the organization is everything to
me. I am also proud to be the best tool for the organization
.
I don't need it
Emotions dull my judgment It's
just a hindrance
But that's the end of this job
You can't beat the human age Are you retiring?
It's a
ninja or an educational institution,
so I'm raising new assassins.This
mission was also a dry run for training newcomers.
I'm still an amateur
.
Why is it targeting you?
Didn't you think so?
Dodge the opponent's hot side and
twist your body to the cold side Why don't you do it?
Did you believe that I would kill you?
I just told
you not to trust me.
Don't you trust Dora
? It's not that it doesn't float, it's that you can't shoot. You
should be aware of the weight of the gun.
It's about time
I think you know it
's me Frozen
Hey, it seems like you forced yourself to succeed
Thank you
Electrician, I'm happy to retire
Thank you so far No
I sympathize with the students It's
there
Please act accordingly
Is your partner alive
?  But it's a name you have I like a
name that doesn't stand out
This time I'm Alan Smith or a boring smile It's
a name that I'm likely to
get Two tickets to Japan's best
I'm going to see a ninja
Even with this, there's nothing I can do
This is the end of this mission
, and my life as an answerer
Game a After hearing that Flight 125 was hijacked
, I cut off communication
.
It's a funeral
What kind of person is
good at hand-cranking? Hijacking is a lie.
I can understand but I can't
go this far to kill just one person The
funeral is going to assassinate me
and you're the tool for that
So yeah
I told the border patrol that the drone was
swollen to chase me o I ca
n't stand there
[music]
Is this the reason why I wanted to take advantage of this
early morning Is he still alive?
I didn't think
even the gorgeous flowers would surprise
me.
But I was betrayed
Why
, Waseda
Nagase, it's
frustrating,
it's
the
feelings I had killed come back to life.
Hmm, can you explain a lot of things? I invited the spirit of the right hand
By the way, I'm a goddess
Can you tell me why you chose me
? You have a choice.
Everything disappears and I sleep
with someone else In other words, I'm a god
right now.
A rough life is
good Ray Changer In
a way, it's synonymous with this life continuing
I think it's an attractive proposal
So it's a matter of request
Who do you want me to kill?
That's the only thing I can think of for a request, so it's
helpful because it's quick and helpful.As
expected, this is the soul that I've teamed up
with.I'm going to go to the sex
doctor.You will be reincarnated in a fantasy world of swords and magic
Tradition
Yes, you should assassinate the geniuses there
Mn Lessons that adore nu do ni Delicious ani [music] Mn Ah ah ah
I'm exhausted
right now meme
snow battery green
me
[music]
1 dan
4 but I
want to go  stuff
nime
[music]
you anisan
ni
[music]
nao n
next time
ceiling deal